hails of guys my name is ash owner and
welcome back to episode 126 of game
programming so it's been awhile since
the last episode we had the whole
Civilization series there in between so
the first thing I want to start off this
video with is just saying that if you
guys haven't watched the Civilization
series I highly recommend you go watch
that right now because that's part of
this series as well I just wanted to
make it a standalone series so that
people not watching game programming
could also watch the Sarai's Asian
series and you know enjoy that so
there'll be a link in the description to
the playlist for all of those videos
that series is complete basically the
last time you would have remembered that
we left off well I mean we created like
this net player thing and we just ended
up having this kind of fake player here
in in the middle here of our level and
the biggest thing that we were kind of
trying to solve I guess was being able
to send data of course because we're
doing multiplayer now we've started
we've started our long journey towards
implementing multiplayer and the biggest
kind of aspect of multiplayer of course
but from the actual network code is the
actual transmission of data right so we
need to be able to both send and receive
data in some kind of format so what we
did in that Sarai's Asian series was
create that format and create a whole
library really that would allow us to
serialize and deserialize data right
that's the whole idea of that right so
we created this thing called rain cloud
because it's kind of like rain which is
the name of our game plus cloud because
you know it's like on the cloud it's
like a network thing anyway it was
pretty funny it was pretty good name
anyway but the wall that aside and we
created rain cloud and that was like our
library that we could use to basically
set a bunch of like fields like we could
pretty much like I mean ultimately you
could copy pretty much any objects
higher like any object that we have in
our game we could kind of I guess
convert into this format and then send
that over the network to someone else
who could then kind of receive that data
D Sarai's it
then actually use it right and that's
the whole idea of how multiplayer is
going to work of course it's just going
to be basically packing the data we want
to send into this format sending that
format as a bunch of packets and then
you know converting that format into
something that we can use on the other
side okay that's it so that being said
go ahead and watch that series if you
haven't already because it'll teach you
a lot probably but if you like what I'm
gonna do right now is I'm going to
pretend that that series never happened
I'm just going to basically go to
github.com full slash the Cherno four
slash java civilization which is the
actual github repository this is again
i'll leave a link in the description to
this as well but basically this is all
of the code that we have this is all we
need in we've actually got two things
here we've got sandbox which is um kind
of an example use case which we might
actually refer to because i have kind of
forgotten how to use this in a while but
then of course this rain cloud stuff is
actually the code that we're looking for
so we're gonna set that up right now
inside our rain project because we want
to be able to use that library to well
you know to convert all of our objects
to love it all of our data into this
format so that we can then send it so
the first thing we'll do is i mean you
can clone the github repository if you
want i'm just going to download it as a
zip file because I don't really care
about maintaining any kind of like this
is never gonna be updated probably but
also I just literally just want the rain
cloud civilization project here so I'll
copy that I'll go to my workspace which
is basically just the location of well
this particular workspace you'll notice
I only have one project in here that I
would recommend that you well
essentially a workspace in Eclipse works
kind of similarly to how a solution does
in Visual Studio right if you're
familiar with that for some reason then
basically that that's kind of how it
works right so every time you start a
new project like if it's a if it's a
fairly if it's a fairly large project
like this one is for example
you'll probably have a bunch of
different projects in your kind of
workspace which all kind of link
together right so like if I for example
wanted to make some tools like to help
us edit levels or like a level viewer
tool I would also make like it as a
separate project inside this workspace
so the way that I treat workspaces is
essentially like visual studio solutions
in the sense that this is a collection
of projects that relate to kind of one
you know one main project right and in
this case that project is rained so that
being said you can see that inside this
workspace I only have that one project
and on what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
copy that rain cloud civilization thing
and paste it into in here right and so
this actually just contains the project
is zooming go like class path projects
but pretty much everything I want here
and then all like all I really want to
do now is since I'm already in this
workspace and I can close that other
thing all I really need excuse me only
aura all I really need to do is just
create a new Java project which has the
same name right and it'll automatically
configure everything and import that
project into this like workspace because
the other thing that's missing right now
is I mean inside I'm not a hundred
percent sure where this is in Eclipse
because Eclipse like just loves to like
look at all this stuff there's so much
stuff going on here but somewhere in
here it's got a list of projects that
are inside this workspace and all of all
we really need to do is just add this
existing project into there so the the
best way I found doing that is just
making a new project with the same name
rather than importing an existing
project which I mean I mean I remember
back in the day used to be terrible
maybe it's good now but this is also
easy so name it the exact same thing as
this folder which contains your source
directory and your class path on your
project and then just hit finish okay
cool so you should be able to browse the
code and everything should be fine we
should have pretty much everything that
we I mean this is just a library that
this doesn't have like a main method or
anything you might be able to run this
but you also don't need to run this
we're just going to use it in our
other project so the big question now is
how do we actually get you know this
rain cloud civilization how do we link
it to this rain project so that we can
actually use it inside there's some
inside this you know this project or
inside our game so the way that we do
that and again I covered this in like
the first a second or I don't know I
covered this in one of the utilization
episodes as well but it's really easy
you just need to right-click on the
project on rain in our case hit
properties you've got to go to your Java
build path projects and then just add
this rain cloud civilization as a
project to this okay so basically this
will just set it as one of the required
projects like for the build path overall
for the building essentially so if we
hit OK you'll notice that whatever name
space we had here or whatever package we
had in here which was combed off the
Cherno dot like a rain cloud for example
you can see that now it's actually like
accessible okay so what we'll do is well
I mean right now we'll just test this
out I didn't want to make this episode
too long in fact I'm gonna try and make
shorter episodes and put them out more
frequently rather than longer episodes
less frequently because I feel that I'll
keep you guys more engaged and also
it'll be easier for me so what I'll do
is just for this video we'll we'll kind
of just I guess use this so I'll go back
to the example real quick so in the
sandbox we've got main I think was just
really just or Sam walks these look at
this him anyway okay so here we go so
what we did was okay so the the approach
that we took was creating actuals it was
like an actual mythical serialize and
deserialize in every single class that
kind of needs to be serializable which
is fine and then we just did so created
a database we created an object we out
of certain strings fields blah blah blah
and then we serialize it to a file and
then the loading side of that is
so I'll refer to this so we'll go ahead
and let's just let's just for example
grab our I don't know what something
okay let's just sterilize like this
cratons width and height just for fun
just to test this out really so we've
got I'll make a quick private void save
we'll call that so we'll make a database
we'll call it screen remember this is
just the name of the database not the
file we will add an object so I guess we
need to create an object first we'll
call it dimensions or resolution about
that we'll add two fields to this so
we'll add a field called width actually
we need to create this using hace field
into just the two integer fields one
will be called width and we'll have a
value of whatever width is will have
height as well and I'm probably missing
got an extra bracket there extra
parentheses so then we'll add the object
to the database and then we'll just do
database serialize to file we'll put
this in our resources may be data and
I'll call this screen beam or something
okay
so done so if I launch the game now
looks like we get an error because isn't
final file specified that's odd
does this follow me to talk because the
direction it needs to exist yeah this is
a bit of mine I think the directory just
needs to exist
so if we go back here rez data then that
works okay cool
so now you can see that inside data we
should have the screen up in thing and
if we open this and like sublime text or
something you know well actually I don't
know why I ever did that's pretty
useless isn't it in our little hex
editor h XD how to recommend there you
can see we've got screen well of last a
DB with height set to whatever and then
if we wanted to deserialize that just
for fun then we can make a quick load
thing so for example let's quickly bring
this out into a private void set size
right and I hope this isn't like some
kind of okay that's fine we'll cut this
and we'll do set size so we'll do this
I'll see database DB called RC database
dot easterlies and file now I believe
what this does is if we give it res data
screen bin I believe what this will do
is unfortunately not I was hoping it
would just okay well we can modify it
but then I hope you want to find it oh I
assumed we can just return like now or
something if it doesn't work out so in
this case if we do something like this
instead of that catastrophe then we'll
just say that if DB equals null then we
will take the existing worth and higher
which we have already set up by this
width thing and hunt otherwise
or in fact if TB doesn't equal null
here's what we will do instead we'll
just do with equals I guess scale is
something we probably want to save as
well just scales done so we'll do
something like with equals DB dot so I
guess I should get the object right so
ask the object objects RC object dot
that's not what I want at all
DB don't get or find object name will be
resolution object I have no idea how to
use my own API find field like yes and
then how do we get as an integer
I'll get int right so we'll find the
field of width height and scale done
okay so we'll deserialize them if it
exists if not then whatever okay so now
the purpose of this is let's okay let's
do the safe first
just quickly so that we save scale as
well but the idea is that if we were to
you know do the save here or something I
think I made that load yeah we'll get
overload if I run this now hopefully
what you'll see is the same result
right however now it's actually reading
it from the file so if I was to edit
this now this is going to be a little
bit difficult to edit because of binary
but we'll do it so let's say where's the
width width and then was it was the
actual width I guess this is the actual
width no idea
I guess there's these four bytes of the
ends other width okay so whatever let's
just change DC to like AC
and save that I'm no idea what its gonna
do okay that worked kind of okay that
did work the reason that it didn't work
full is just because of our thing you
can see that the window that I opened
was less wide yeah which is the idea
because I reduced the width but the
reason that we had the crash was because
this buffered image and all this stuff
that gets created actually gets created
based on the size so we need to fix that
and we can fix that pretty easily just
by doing this right for now at least
this will kind of set the size I guess
so if we run this now hopefully okay you
can see it works right we've still got
like rendering errors that's to be
expected because we don't support
resolutions like that but you can see
that by doing something like this we can
of course change this so AC let's make
it really small let's make it like three
or something because it's nice and
narrow now right so I think DC was the
initial thing okay great so you can see
kind of how we can now serialize data
very easily it's incredibly easy to both
save data and then also load data and of
course if we didn't have this file like
if this file word should get deleted for
some reason then it would just
automatically whatever this is so you
can see the file doesn't exist right now
actually would have gotten recreated so
far doesn't exist right now and we ended
up with a very wide screen okay cool so
anyway that's the way that that works no
matter normal you can see how we can
easily kind of use this realization in
library to you know even do really
really simple things the other really
cool thing that we could do is
ultimately use this as like a data kind
of tool so to speak right so in other
words instead of us instead of us taking
in certain parameters like we're not
really modeling gameplay right now but
if we were then this is just a desire to
like inspire you guys I guess but like
for example wetware
you know working on particle animation
instead of having to have all these
values all these magic kind of values
here that we use all the time that you
know are only really tweakable this
isn't as big as the problem in Java by
the way because really it just means
that if we want to tweak them we can
just tweak them hit control s and it'll
automatically like hot replace our code
for us but the idea is that obviously if
this was like C++ or really anything
except for Java then having like as
their I'd just like a sterilization file
that we could just reload that had all
of our data and there would be awesome
because it means that we can kind of
even like even go as far as to create a
tool that we could just use to edit
values inside this database instead of
having to use a hex editor or something
to tweak certain parameters and then see
them applied in the game in real time
right but again with Java we can kind of
do the hot code replacing so it's not as
big of a deal but it's still pretty cool
and the reason you would want to do
stuff like that is because of course it
just means that you're separating your
data from your code which is pretty much
always a good idea because you know for
example if we were on to it essentially
the whole reason you you want to
separate data from card so to speak is
because like daughter is more or less
like an asset right like certain
parameters in your game for example like
the statistics of enemies or something
and like potentially you know like how
powerful certain weapons are for example
that stuff is not really at all the
programmers job right it's it's usually
like done by the designer or something
and a those people usually you know
don't don't want to be editing source
code even if they can write code they
don't want to be editing source code but
also it means that if you kind of
separate those not only does it mean
that they can kind of edit a certain
they can use a certain program like a
certain tool or a certain even just like
notepad or something to edit certain
values and tweak them outside of the
game source code it also means that they
are literally separate files and so they
can be updated without actually changing
the binaries of the game which is also
important right so the idea is that
tying data took
kotas not always it's not it's not ideal
and by doing something like this it also
means that you know we to an extent you
know all you have to do is just you know
that's screened up in file you replace
it with something else and it will do
whatever that file says right so it
becomes really really convenient and of
course as we explore networking and
multiplayer we also realize that it also
means that we can send data pretty
easily you can see the like saving and
creating a new database and saving you
know three fields until it was as simple
as this right and I mean that creates a
file that creates quite a tiny file as
well like that bin files probably like I
don't know first we can probably check
if we were really keen screened up in
I'm picky you eighty four bytes right
tiny it could be a lot smaller of course
I mean if you you you could go to the
extreme of just storing like anyway the
point is that we have we have this
format now that we can use and we'll we
will be extensively using that for
networking all right cool so if you guys
enjoyed this video please hit the like
button a few things I want to mention
real quick is if you want to discuss
this video in more of more or less like
a real-time fashion then I highly
recommend that you join my slack I've
got a slack account here or a slack team
all you have to do is enter your email
address and you'll be able to join
essentially like what is an instant
messenger so here's like an example of
the game programming channel it's got a
lot of trapped I've got quite a few
channels here but basically it's all
it's all totally like real-time the game
every channel isn't very active against
because I haven't probably been putting
out too many videos but there are 122
people here so if you guys have any
questions we just want to talk about
this episode or maybe you have some
other questions or problems you're
having with your game programming source
code then join slack using this if you
haven't already and then just go to join
the game programming channel and you'll
be able to talk about game programming
also if you guys want access to the
source code of game programming I mean
obviously rain cloud civilization is up
and get help for free but if you want to
access the rain source code
then all you have to do is go to my
patreon and pledge at least five dollars
per month and if you do so first of all
what supports me making more game
programming videos but also it gives you
access to this private github repository
where every single you perform saying
all the source code over here right you
also get to see like pretty much every
commit as it goes along so for example
in episode 125 you can easily like diff
the changes from last episode and it's
just really really convenient because
yeah I mean if you're into that then
it's it's definitely a good way to help
me out and also get rewarded for that
alright that's it I hope you guys
enjoyed next episode will hopefully be
in within a week I do want to start
punching these out a bit more often and
yeah hope you guys enjoyed this and I'll
see you next time goodbye
you